this episode is sponsored by endl an app
that creates personalized soundscapes to
help you focus relax and sleep the first
hundred people to click on the link in
the description will get a free week of
audio experiences
[Music]
[Music]
every experiment has to start somewhere
this one began in a container full of
dying microbes and the five cute pink
ciliates called a blepharisma that james
our master of microscopes carefully
transferred to a new flask for rescue
within that flask was clean water and a
few grains of wheat
but those grains were not there to feed
the blepharisma
they were there to feed the other hidden
residents of the flask the bacteria
expanding their numbers to create a
buffet for the blepharisma to eat and in
their new home with its plentiful fields
of bacteria to graze on the blepharisma
thrived they divided sometimes multiple
times per day so that 5 became 10 became
20 became 40 and so on
after only 25 rounds of division those
five cells had become more than 150
million
iterations of themselves and in just two
weeks
what was a fresh flask full of clean
water had become tinged with flecks of
red pigmented with a thriving population
of blepharisma descended from just a
handful
of survivors
if microbes like the blepharism can make
so many of themselves in such a short
amount of time why is our planet not
just completely coated in any single
species why don't we see this reddish
water everywhere chock full of
blepharisma well for one the flask these
blepharisma reside in is an idealized
world with endless nutrients and
countless bacteria not to mention an
intervening master of microscopes but
the world outside of this flask is far
less simple there are so many organisms
to compete with all trying to make a
life out of the space and food and
oxygen available to them and those
resources are constantly in flux
heightening the stakes as organisms
contend for the possibility of future
shortages but the problem for
blepharisma is not just the intricacies
of ecology they face another threat and
it is not a threat that you or i or many
other organisms on this earth could ever
relate to we are talking of course about
giant cannibals
the cannibals in this flask did not make
their appearance known until james began
to reduce the amount of food he added to
this culture of blepharisma which makes
sense cannibalism doesn't necessarily
make for a good survival strategy when
your species is attempting to make more
of itself taking the time to chow down
on each other just seems
counterproductive and yet there are
various ciliates that have been observed
eating their own kind for example our
favorite blue trumpets stenter corulius
have been documented tearing chunks off
of other stenter coruliuses grabbing
them by the tail and swallowing them
while we haven't been able to record a
successful cannibalistic stenter we have
seen them try like this one attempting
to get its mouth around the other in
this case the targeted individual was
able to get away probably because it was
too big for the other stenter to
actually fit into its mouth there's a
lesson in here for ciliates pursuing the
cannibalistic lifestyle it is not enough
to be vicious you also need to be big
ciliates do not have forks and knives to
carve up their plate of food they don't
even have limbs
what most ciliates do have
is an oral groove an opening lined with
hair to stir up a vortex and draw in
food so whatever food they're eating
ciliates have only a few options they
can jab away at their prey tearing
chunks off in the process or they can
engulf it in one piece
and for most blepharisma peacefully
minding their own business with bacteria
meals that's fine
but cannibalism demands more
the blepharisma needs to be big enough
to eat other blepharisma and that is why
cannibalistic blepharisma also tend to
be giant blepharisma
ciliate cannibalism
is not very well understood and so the
exact relationship between size and
cannibalism is murky are the blepharisma
cannibals because they are giants or are
they giants because they are cannibals
in nature maybe it's a bit of both but
in the lab well scientists have realized
that there is a more intriguing
possibility and our own blepharisma have
shown this it is the possibility that
you can actually intentionally turn your
jolly pink ciliates into cannibals
like we said at the beginning every
experiment has to start somewhere and in
the 1930s the scientist arthur c gisa
started with a group of blepharisma that
had grown up on bacteria these
blepharisma were content with their
smaller meals and cannibalism was rare
but gesa hypothesized that this piece
was a conditional one that resulted
simply from the fact that the
blepharisma he was looking at were all
too close in size for any individual to
pursue cannibalism but what if one could
make a larger blepharisma
that is what giza decided to find out
and his method was pretty simple to get
a bigger blepharisma feed them bigger
food
the blepharous mahi was working with
weren't large enough to eat each other
yet but they could eat a ciliate called
tetrahymena that was smaller than them
but larger than bacteria
after eating the tetrahymena the
blepharisma grew their mouths were
larger and even their macronucleus had
expanded to almost three times the size
as their bacteria-fed counterparts then
starved of their tetrahymena diets the
giant blepharisma were set upon a batch
of blepharisma that were small enough to
stuff in their microbial gullet
the smaller plethorisma but did not
stand a chance
within minutes most of the giant
blepharisma giza observed had eaten at
least one blepharism eight hours later
he found one giant
had eaten twelve
and while they are quick to be captured
the ingested blepharism's death is slow
the cannibal might take around thirty
seconds to engulf their prey but gisa
reported seeing the captured
swimming laps inside food vacuoles for
up to an hour
after which the digestion began to kick
in
the cannibalism giza observed was not
permanent though eventually after being
starved the giant cannibals he had
cultivated divided several times
creating smaller versions of themselves
in the process
bringing his experiment full circle
small blepharisma sustaining larger
blepharisma who eventually return to
their small size until the call for
cannibalism
strikes again
the blepharism in our flask grew up
differently than geeses did they were
not separated into two batches and fed
different diets that would eventually
drive the physical differences that
would make one group cannibalistic yet
there were still blepharisma that grew
into giants capable of cannibalism and
we don't know the mechanisms that
spurred those changes
whether there was something in these
organisms pasts that predisposed some of
them toward gigantism nor do we know
what their futures look like and whether
it will be
full of cannibalism
every experiment has to start somewhere
but by the end it is only a snapshot of
a moment in time one that captures the
effects of many mysterious histories and
also the beginning of many unknown
futures
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you again to endl for
sponsoring this episode endl is an app
that takes everything we know about
sound combines it with technology and
creates personalized soundscapes to help
you focus relax and sleep their app was
named the apple watch app of the year in
2020 and their study soundscape is a
nice way to stay calm and concentrated
while learning
sound has a direct impact on your
physical and mental well-being and by
adapting in real time to things like
your location weather and heart rate
endle creates simple pleasant sounds
that can help to calm your mind so
whether you're struggling to get a good
deep sleep or you need to focus while
you study endle can help you out if
you're interested in trying out endl
just be one of the first 100 people to
download it using the link in the
description and you will get a free week
of audio experiences
[Music]
quick shout out to all the people whose
names are on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons and we know that
if we put them all in a tank together
none of them would grow extra giant and
consume the rest right
right
i need you all to agree that none of you
would become giant cannibals
well now i'm a little bit worried about
that maybe we should add a little form
you have to fill out when you sign up to
be a patron if you would like to be one
of the patrons of journey to the
microcosm because you think that stuff
like this should exist you can go to
patreon.com
journeytomicro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out jam
and germs on instagram and if you want
to see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
[Music]
you